[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんが
僕の動画
世界一黒い部屋の動画
すでに見られましたでしょうか今皆さんの
目に映っているここがそう
世界一黒い部屋
真っ黒でしょう
完全にエイトさんの香水のMVですまぁ
すごいですよ
本当に真っ暗で照明つけてても全然映らな
いって俺の顔と服以外ほんと真っ黒って
いう
あ来ました
俺
だー
飽きてしまったので今日はこの部屋別の
部屋に改造しようと思います皆さんは
佐伯性反射ということのご存知でしょうか
大気性反射どの方向から光が当たっても光
が入ってきた同じ軌道に反射する気候
分からんなわからん何だそれはそれは何だ
ただ一つわかってること
めっちゃ綺麗なんですよこれも再生反射
反射する
素材がここでできてるんですけども例えば
ライトを当ててみますね今からちょ今から
自分で写真撮りますね
はい
ブサイクすぎて無理
はいこれです皆さん見てください
すごくないですかすごくないですか胸の
部分これが再帰性反射なんかこうオーロラ
というかなんかこう虹色の馬の表現でき
ないこんな色になるんですけども今回です
ねこの記事この部屋全面分準備しました
皆さんもお分かりでしょうこの世界一黒い
部屋を今からこの
佐伯製反射の存在で全て
覆い隠し全てを監視する最強の部屋を作り
たいと思います
インスタ映え間違いなし皆さんフォロー
よろしくお願いします
また
終わりましたというわけで素材が届きまし
た多分普通ねこんな
ヘアサイズにこの素材つかちゃダメなんす
よこの服作ってる会社に問い合わせで自ら
なんとかしてこの部屋を
部屋にしたいっていう話をしたところなん
と
協力してくださって準備してくれたって
感じです
今まだよくわからないんですけれどもこれ
をスマホで撮ってみてくださいクラッシュ
を炊いてどうでしょう
これがかっこいいんですよ
全部これにしたい
[音楽]
すごい
いやこれマジで
世界一やばいにはできるよよしじゃあ早速
どんどん貼っていきましょうちゃんと
増やしたかないとこの模様にはならないの
でこの素材貼ってる時はあんまり分かり
づらいと思うんですけど
完成して
写真撮ったら
宇宙です貼っていきましょうまずじゃあ床
引いてみようかな
引くだけでも相当可哀想あとなんか
ポイントとしてはちょっとくしゃくしゃっ
てなってた方が綺麗になるらしいです
わざとちょっと腐らせながら撮ってみます
はい
床だけこの素材でできましたこれどうなる
んだろう寝っ転がって写真撮ってみよう
もう結構やばい気がするけど
写真撮りますはい
チーズ
[音楽]
[笑い]
すごいこれ
すごいわマジでちょっとこれ以上写真撮る
のやめるわ中途半端な状態で撮るの
もったいないからもう完成まで僕は取り
ません
皆さんも完成をお楽しみに
[音楽]
はいみなさん5時間が経過しました
ようやくようやくついに完成しました
すべてが反射する禁断の部屋3人ぐらいで
作ってるんですけどももう目が目が
チカチカしてマジでやばかったです
とりあえず見ますありがとうみましょうか
では入ります
こちらです
はい
皆さん見てわかったと思うんですけども今
のところ大したことないでしょ
[音楽]
出てますけども
普通のこういう照明だとまだ本領は発揮さ
れてないんですよハウス的な要素がまだ
少なくてまあ普通のなんかね
わちょっとなんかテカテカしたような部屋
じゃないぐらいどまりこんな感じです次は
フラッシュを焚きながら入ってみたいと
思いますもうパッと見普通ですよいきます
はいもうおかしい今の隙間見ました皆さん
どうなってんだこれいきますよ
やばい
[音楽]
すごい
やばい
グリーンバックの中にいるみたいな
すごい
浮いてる
嘘
すごいはい今フラッシュなしで撮影して
ますどうでしょうそんなに多分反射とかも
してないしまあなんかちょっと暗い部屋
ぐらいな感じまこんな感じなんですけども
フラッシュ台にすると
[音楽]
どうでしょう
これが反射の力ですなんかそうすると反射
のつかみみたいになっちゃう
やっぱやばいね
そこいると頭おかしくなってそうマジで
すげえよこれマジで
落ち着く
落ち着くんですかここというわけで早速
ループツアーしていきたいと思いますまず
こちらの扉ですね何かはわからない扉は
もう全部この布で覆うと完全に見えなく
なるしもう
壁も全部こんな感じで
もう全面埋めさせてもらいました
壁
でここも全部こうなってて
ここもこの素材でできております
床もせめてこの素材で作らせていただき
ました
異世界に飛ばされた人数なんですよね
[音楽]
リアルなんよこれ
俺たちにゴールデン技術はない
と思うんですよ
ほんと違うよってそのまま出してるから
動画はい
合成でこんな速度であの編集できないので
合成はこれで皆さん信じましたか本当に
こういう部屋になっている
ほらもうもうほんとですから
天井ねちょっと待って1個行っていいこの
部屋ずっと間違ってもおかしくなるどう
なってる
頭をピカピカ
すごい
すごいよ
完全に浮いてるっすね本当に
[音楽]
ちょっと倍の写真撮ろうぜひ撮りましょう
はいというわけで
早速管理人に見せたいと思います
お疲れ様ですお
疲れ様です
[音楽]
じゃあ早速入っちゃってもらって
はいはい
目瞑っててね塗ってますはいはいはい
じゃあ早速
開けてみてください行きますはいあれ
ここってあれでも黒い部屋
[音楽]
ちょっと
色変えたって感じかな
ちょっとなんか紫っぽい感じになった
テロペロン
[音楽]
取っちゃいますね皆さん行きますよはい
はい
チーズ
取れました
[音楽]
何これ
全てが反射する部屋です
写真撮ったらじゃあ
クラッシュオンにしてみてください
[音楽]
なんかサーモグラフィーみたいな感じで
すごい
すごくない
ほらもう
なんかあれどうせみたいこれ
みんなそういう